you know what's something that uh twitch
streaming is uh made me feel a lot more
i feel like i
uh
i really feel a lot
more strong about the viewers who like
uh turn up like everyday to this [ __ ]
yeah i don't know why because like you
know when you're youtubing i see that
that [ __ ] uh
who's a ninja guy who comments on every
video that guy without mustache there's
like there's like 500 of these channels
right you're like alright the same
people can't whatever but like on twitch
it's like all right i know a bunch of
the names of people who like turn up
every single time there's this uh person
called like blue sky days who every
single stream gives me five subs and i
feel like they've made it into a ritual
they just shout out thank you i really
appreciate it uh yeah but like to me
it's like
again going back to the hate stuff as
well it's like all right when i
think about getting sad about some
people not liking what you do or
whatever i'm like okay but like how much
more would it hurt me if i had to
explain to say that person who maybe
turns up all the time be like hey by the
way uh i'm quitting uh i don't like this
because some people said mean things
about me i feel like seeing that person
be like oh
you're gonna quit but i like watching
your stuff that would hurt me way more
than anything anyone could say oh yeah
of course of course connor's fell off
ratio you know whatever
that that you know that nothing yeah
yeah of course of course i mean to me
like i i feel the same with like some of
my patrons because i like i have i have
patrons who have been fans of me for
like who have been watching me since
right right since like you know [ __ ] 10
years ago or something and they've like
they've been there since the start of
when i opened my patreon and they're
still with me to like to this day and
i'm just like that's that's [ __ ]
insane you know that's like you know
shout outs shout out to all you guys in
the patreon discord server because uh
it's like i i like having my patreon
discord server because it's just like a
very close-knit community and it's just
you know
it's it's it's nice having just familiar
faces that have just yeah it's like it
is it's just like stuck with you for
that long you know it it
it makes you feel what's the word not
validated but just happy that you kind
of do what you do you know yeah very
much i definitely feel that way as well
about like you know like youtuber
friends who were there since like the
very beginning right now yeah i have a
couple who were still around uh like you
know back when i had like [ __ ] less
than a thousand subs right i was doing
like gaming videos and [ __ ] like i still
talk to a lot of them and like you know
if i would yeah again same thing like if
i would just one day be like
yeah i kind of just [ __ ] hate this
you know people are [ __ ] on me blah
blah blah then you know i would it's
like betraying a family member yeah yeah
you know it's like they've been there
they've seen you know thick and thin of
me and being like nah dude you got this
and they've like believed in me the
entire time right yeah and then for me
to just be like
i can't take a bunch of people uh you
know giving me [ __ ] for saying that jude
zukaisen was okay i'm sorry i have to i
was considering the podcast i was like
[ __ ] joey yeah i have to go ignorant
[Music]
didn't like jujutsu
i'm done it's over with i didn't say i
didn't like it
it's okay you didn't you did you didn't
come it's just okay that is offensive to
everything i i hold dear
the more you say it the more offensive
stop
i don't know how this is happening
am i supposed to rephrase it it was
average it wasn't everything i i'm not
even going to entertain you on this it
might look better than average why do
you think i don't want to start these
conversations these are the kind of
people that will say it's average and
then give love life a seven out of ten
you know what i mean it's like i can't
stand this oh i mean i i don't even want
to get into love like he's kidding me
[ __ ] that
i'm just you just
saying all the love my fans with that
conversation i'm not going to engage in
for good reason i know i know a lot of
love my friends i'm just i'm hating on
you guys i'm sorry okay
i'm just joshing with you guys
they won't take it that way
i can't believe you took this as a joke
here goes my l this week yeah
there's no cancellation no i i you know
uh wait sorry i was gonna say i was
gonna say we're very fortunate that uh
you know on youtube it's hard to have uh
not hard but it can be quite difficult
to be friends have have good friendship
with other youtubers for a long period
of time because of the nature of the job
definitely it just uh you know things
change people get busy people move
people get on with their life do
different content fall off ratio all
that kind of stuff you know like the
work so you know very very lucky there
were some good friends and we've been
friends for very long time we all happen
to kind of be around the same kind of
sphere and do the same thing same time
it all kind of worked out very lucky and
i think yeah that's like another thing
as well is that like i think you know
like if we're going back to like you
know uh
[ __ ] helpful advice for like people
starting off right like another one that
i get often as well is that like oh what
do i do about like collabing and stuff
you know because like you know i feel
that's like the easiest way to grow out
your channel from an early stage and i'm
like yes in a sense if you do it right
um but you know
you shouldn't be like a channel with 200
subs and [ __ ] dming felix to like
collab with you right like that's you
know you got to know your boundaries and
stuff like that and also like another
piece of advice that i saw uh on twitter
the other day which i thought was very
true was that um you know i think a lot
of like youtubers have this like weird
especially those starting off have this
like weird misunderstanding that they
think everyone who collabs with them is
also a friend of theirs
and that is just unfortunately not true
a lot of people who just see it as
business who just want to do this
one-time thing or just to do this thing
to benefit
themselves but also you know the person
they're collabing with yeah and it's
it's almost unhealthy to see
a person who you collab with as just
your mate yeah
there's a very big difference between a
collaborator and an actual friend yeah
and i think like once you've like really
fully started to understand that at an
early stage and really gone and thought
to yourself okay who is actually my
friend
like someone who will hang out with me
when the cameras are not rolling
and who is someone that is just there
for the clout do you have a hard time
drawing that line like
no
no no
it's like you know i
i've done this for long enough now i
know i know just like being an adult
right you just kind of god forbid i have
to be an adult uh you know you kind of
learn just uh you you know you vibe with
people sometimes you don't vibe with
people sometimes someone is really like
you really love what they make and you
really like
how they go about it
and sometimes you hang out with them and
it just didn't it didn't click you know
yeah it's kind of weird the conversation
was a little like oh okay and other
times it's like holy [ __ ] like i i got
on so well with this person but then
maybe you feel that way and they don't
which is then this is an experienced
thing we have to learn all right okay
even if i really like that person i like
hanging out with them i want to talk to
them again it's like you got to be like
normal about it
let's hang out next day let's do it you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah i spaced it out
yeah i don't know how we got to like
that uh i don't know how we became super
close but i i
because i remember there was definitely
a time when i was like yeah these guys
are cool but i don't want to like burden
them
i don't want to like text them too much
because i remember like when i met gone
we didn't really talk in between hanging
out it was kind of like we'd hang out
and then it was like a
thing i don't really know i mean you
sent me a [ __ ] email
i don't know how that worked i would
have put that right in the trash yeah
i mean i i'm the type of guy who really
connects with someone hanging out yeah
yeah i'm saying
like personally or physically you know
like i don't need to touch your face
lick your sweat suck your gadgets
if you're a jojo
i didn't know what you were talking
about there
was sexually
you are not a friend of mine until i
suck your dick
god is harvey wyatt
i i was i was i was going to mention i'm
the type of guy who might not talk so
much like online or wrong
sexually harass people
why it was just like like visual like
whiplash for me because i was trying to
make this poignant point and kind of
just goes god sucks dick he's like sweat
that was a weird time at the onsen
pretty sure i was told that's how you do
it
yeah because i remember we you know we
didn't message too much but we had a fun
time hanging out whenever we did hang
out in person and uh we just ended up
hanging more times in person and uh i
guess
it just happened naturally right but i
mean yeah going off going from what you
said about you know being friends versus
collaborators i
like even me as someone who doesn't
collab too much i mean i barely clap at
all um but even me as a content creator
i can already
you know there are some content creators
who you enjoy their content and you
really respect the work that they do but
you know there are some people that you
just think yeah i probably wouldn't get
along with you
i love the work you do but i probably
would not get along with you and on the
opposite end there are also other people
who you don't like their content but
you're like maybe i can get along with
this guy
definitely seems seems like it seems
like a chill dude or something yeah
absolutely and you know it's that whole
thing of like separating the artist from
the odd right which is you know
way easier said than done in a lot of
cases yeah it's just tough
yeah i also it just feels like it's been
so long since i've been able to like
meet a lot of new content creators who
i've watched because of the past two
years you know because we've only been
able to meet people in japan right and i
feel like now normally like you get you
get a point every year where you get to
this opportunity to fly out to america
or fly out
and actually meet fellow content
creators and i just feel like i've
forgotten what i've forgotten what that
feels like now yeah i've forgotten what
it feels like just to like just to have
that like first people just just have
like the first awkward meeting of just
oh hey i i watch your stuff yeah i like
what you do you know and you're like
i miss just getting to speak english to
people
i just want to speak english to someone
do you remember the first time you met
someone online who you knew online yeah
but you'd never like met in real life
did dremel do you remember what that
feeling's like oh
cause it's always like i i know like one
of the biggest things i first notice
it's always height always hype oh yeah
yeah they are never the height you
expect them to be oh yeah you know
that's that's that's true on my end as
well because every time someone meets me
the fir that's the first comment every
time it's either height or depending on
if you're a content creator who shows
their face or not it's also like how
they look as well yeah i definitely got
that when uh when i first met john super
eye patchwolf because you know he's in
almost all his videos he never shows his
face yeah so for the longest time people
didn't know what he looked like yeah
yeah and then you know obviously when he
first blew up everyone was like all the
antitubers were like this guy's
content's [ __ ] amazing it's great i
would love to meet him and then when we
heard that he was coming to ax everyone
was like it was like a [ __ ] ax guest
he was like yo hype super high
vegetables coming to ax dude let's
[ __ ] go and then you you know you you
go to the gathering yeah and there's a
bunch of faces there that you think
might be super impactful right but you
don't know who right because you've
never seen his face yeah yeah and then
when you meet him finally
i remember the the first thing i said to
john i was like i'm sorry if this is
weird but you're like really hot
i mean he is
my god if i was a chick i would be head
over heels he is the sigma male yeah he
really is sigma and luckily he took it
in like a good way [ __ ] that [ __ ]
jawline man dude john john please that
man
like dude he could break bricks with
that jaw yeah like it's it's crazy how
hard he is why aren't you more on camera
more i know
you need to show your face more john
you're a good-looking dude although he
did buy a dell computer that was gonna
oh yeah yeah
that was a great that was a great yeah
that was a good video
imagine a dell computer yeah it couldn't
be me but like you know
when it comes to like looks as well but
also like physique and yeah as you said
like height you know like i get my
[ __ ] height pointed at all the
goddamn time and i'm like i never
thought that would be a weird thing yeah
did you ever meet up with people
online often like before youtube was
everything you ever used to do no not
really
yeah
because i feel like i got into i made
online friends because of youtube yeah
same yeah and like not not the other way
around um
so it's
we're now with more especially during
the pandemic with more people making
friends online i'm sure a lot more
people are going to be experiencing this
experience but yeah but like yeah it was
it was like an alien experience to me
the first times the first time i did and
like it's still it's still weird you
never i never get used to meeting
someone who i know online and maybe
especially if they're like a content
creator you know and it feels so weird
now because i'm a content creator and
i've been on the other side of it and i
still like sometimes i just don't know
how to approach someone who i whoms i
know
that's it's so weird it's like it's that
feeling of meeting that content creator
that you've only seen in video yeah
and and the first thing that pops into
your mind is i've only ever seen you
behind the screen like like that
mentality never dies
it's so weird even though i'm also in
that same position now to that other
person it's so weird to say with the one
of my first thoughts is oh that's what
the back of their head looks like
i don't know why why is that because
because it's just not an angle you've
ever seen so it's just it's just weird
it's just so surreal seeing like just
just this angle i'm just like is that
that person and she's like oh wait no it
is that person oh okay
i kind of get one in my head